the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
this is we've got three lectures left
today Thursday and next Tuesday so today
we're going to talk about a little bit
more about modal analysis and we did
initial conditions last time this time
we'll do harmonic excitation mostly a
little review there Thursday Miri say
this is slightly differently modal
analysis looks at the vibration of a
system with many degrees of freedom and
looks at it one mode at a time but you
can also just solve the whole thing at
once you don't have to break it down
into the individual modes so you can
come up with a if you have a harmonic
excitation on a continuing on a system
with many degrees of freedom if you put
in a harmonic force the whole thing is
going to shake and you can solve it in
one go
and that's essentially using a transfer
function approach so this is breaking it
down one mode at a time here we're going
to do this concept of transfer functions
for hij so response at location i due to
an excitation at j a multiple degree of
freedom system you get many different
combinations so this is steady state
response but done all at once and
Tuesday but and also this has an
application to something I called
dynamic absorbers I'll just be able to
scratch the surface of that but the
Hancock building across the way I told
you a couple lectures back about it and
in the 1970s is brand-new and the
windows are falling out and there was
lots of windows falling out at the
bottom and then at the top and the thing
was bended back and forth like a just a
cantilever reading the wind and one of
the fixes for it is they put a thing
called the dynamic
over on the 58th floor there are two 300
ton blocks of lead on a pressurized oil
film so they can slide back and forth on
the 58th floor of that building
they're called dynamic absorbers and at
the expense of letting these big blocks
of lead slide back and forth
it keeps the building from vibrating and
keeps the windows from falling out so
will I hope to get to talking a little
bit about dynamic absorbers one other
way of stopping problem vibration and on
Tuesday we'll talk about strings and
beams just a brief introduction to
continuous systems and that'll be our
last lecture and probably give you a
very quick review then of what's going
to be covered on the final but mostly
the final we'll be covering this last
third of the course on vibration so
let's turn to modal analysis and posted
on stellar as a little two-page handout
that gives you a just step-by-step
cookbook approach to conducting a modal
analysis we're going to hit the
highlights of that this morning as a way
of reviewing what we learned last time
and moving on to calculating the
response to harmonic forces so we begin
with some n degree of freedom system
linearized we're only dealing with
linear equations of motion now and our
first step is we need equations of
motion so you'd write them m
in general you'd write out of your
equations of motion for the system and
these X's here just my generalized
coordinates they can be rotations
deflections whatever makes sense in the
problem that's the first step you need
your equations of motion second step
find undamped natural frequencies the
Omega eyes I'll just call it a mega eyes
and mode shapes and the mode shapes we
put into a matrix that we call the mode
shape matrix I write it as u so that's
the next step in the problem the third
is basically to apply or invoke the
modal expansion theorem this is the key
to the whole thing and that is to say
that you can write the generalized
motions of the system the responses of
the system as a weighted sum of the
individual modes of the system so the
Q's are the modal amplitudes the use or
the mode shape are the each mode like
the first mode has some amplitude and
time dependence and its motion is
distributed to the whole system
according to its mode shape and that's
what that statement is and another way
of writing it which is more intuitive is
this is a summation then of I equals 1
over the degrees of freedom of the
system of the mode shapes times Q I of T
the modal amplitudes or the response of
that single degree of freedom system
scribes each of the modes
Hey
now I should
the QIS are the solution to n equations
of the form mi Qi
double dot plus CI Qi dot plus K I Q I
equals the excitation for that single
degree freedom system so the modal
expansion theorem says we're going to
take each mode of the system treat it
like a single degree of freedom problem
and so for the first mode I would be one
you'd have a modal mass damping
stiffness and a force for that mode and
you know how to solve for the response
of a single degree freedom system to
initial conditions or the steady-state
response to some harmonic input and you
would do that for each of the modes and
to get back to the final answer you some
of them back up again this way so I've
put up here on the board where that the
description of that demo and we went
through all this information last time
so even your notes for last time if you
missed last time I've put it up again so
here's the demo on the table this is
what it's my diagram of it mass one mass
to Spring lowercase K one lowercase K 2
so the lower cases I'm going to use to
describe system parameters upper case
k's and that sort of thing will be my
modal parameters so this has masses
stiffnesses and damping and this damper
is connected to this the non moving
frame and so is this one to model the
damping sliding up and down on that
shaft so the equations of motion of the
system are here in your generalized
coordinates and I've included the
possibility that I can have a force on
the first mass f1 a force on the second
mass so this is a completely general
setup for this problem then to you need
to find the natural frequencies and mode
shapes so you assume a solution of the
form e to the I Omega T plug-in and you
get this algebraic equation minus Omega
squared n plus K times some vector which
will turn out to be the mode shapes and
either this is zero which is trivial or
the determinant of this is zero and this
gives you the roots of this determinant
gives you the natural frequencies of the
system if it's a four degree of freedom
problem you get four roots so we found
for this particular problem that the
natural frequencies are five point six
five and seventeen point six nine and
the mass matrix if you weren't here last
time in kilograms three point one nine
three point six three Oh
and the stiffness matrix in Newton's per
meter for that system is this notice
stiffness matrices are always symmetric
in this one minus 36 minus 36 okay and
many of you have been taking to double O
one have you run in did anybody invoke
something called Maxwell's reciprocal
theorem have you run into that okay
well this comes from structural analysis
this notion of the symmetry of the K
matrix the mass matrix is also going to
be symmetric so we need to find it by
nope to do modal analysis you make this
calculation u transpose mu this is the
transpose of the modal mode shape matrix
mu and if you do that calculation with
these numbers and those mode shapes you
get a new mass you get the modal mass
matrix which is guaranteed to be
diagonal even if it wasn't to begin with
this is the numbers you get the
stiffness matrix certainly wasn't
diagonal to begin with it looked like
that and we multiply u transpose times K
times U and we get a diagonal matrix
this element here we'd call capital k1
it's the modal stiffness for mode 1 this
is the modal mass for mode 1 and they
represent a they're the numbers we need
to write a single degree freedom
equation of motion of the kind at the
bottom of that board up there so we want
to write em 1 Q 1 double dot plus some C
1 Q 1 dot plus K 1 Q 1 equals in general
a this is a 1 some excitation but it's a
single degree freedom system if it's a
single degree freedom system what's its
natural frequency using the parameters
in this equation
right so you may get one had better be e
the square root of K 1 over m 1 and
that's the square root of K 1 as 91 nope
that's that's the real stiffness matrix
I need my u transpose K here 1 1371 1 1
3 point
71 and the modal mass for for system 1
is 3 point 5 5 6 so that's 3 or so into
100 and something that's neighborhood of
35 36 square root of 36 is about 6 so it
needs it needs to give you back exactly
the correct natural frequency which you
found in the beginning when you solve
for the natural frequencies and mode
shapes of the system so I all repeated
myself here but and if you write the
same thing Omega 2 had better be equal
to K 2 over m 2 so these are just ways
of verifying that you've done your
arithmetic correctly okay and I haven't
done the damping matrix yet because the
damping matrices are have to be treated
rather carefully they don't
automatically uncouple and so we'll
we'll address it in just a second the
damping matrix however would be written
u T C you would give me what I hope is a
diagonalized modal damping matrix try to
make these look like caps or something
to make them look a little different
from the C's of the dashpots themselves
we hope to find a diagonalized damping
matrix but we have to do some make some
effort to make that happen
finally one thing we haven't dealt with
before in order to when we derive the
single degree freedom mobile systems we
had to multiply through by this you
transpose the original equations of
motion and what we haven't worked with
yet is how do you get the modal forces
in the system they come from the
calculation u transpose times the
generalized forces in the system so
that's a vector times a matrix gives you
a new vector which are the generalized
forces and we're going to do that
example in more detail in a few minutes
so last time we did the initial
conditions problem and we need the
results of that to do we need the
damping that we learn from that to do
the forced vibration problem so let's go
back and review a little bit about what
we did so let's let for a moment the
generalized forces be zero so no
excitation Anderson so we're only doing
an initial conditions problem and let's
assume that we have some set of initial
conditions on the generalized
displacements at time zero so those
initial conditions on displacements they
look you know something like x1 not down
to X and naught and we just have a two
degree freedom system in our example and
also you could have an X dot at T equals
zero and that would be some vector of V
one zeros down to BN zeros and for today
we're going to let those be zeros so
we're just going to have an initial just
an initial deflection in the system and
see what happens and we learned last
time that since the modal expansion
theorem is what makes this whole thing
work
the idea that X can be written as u
times Q then we ought to be able to say
the same thing for if these are initial
conditions and we should be able to get
the initial conditions in modal
coordinates so X at 0 here is also you
at the Q's at 0 but we normally would
specify these we need to know those well
to get these I just multiply through by
u inverse so that the Q the vector of
the initial displacements in modal
coordinates is just equal to u in
verse x the initial conditions the
initial deflections in the generalized
coordinates and Q dots at zero if you
had nonzero initial velocities would be
u inverse times X dot at time zero
so let me tell you where we're going I'm
not getting a not going to go back all
the way through the initial conditions
problem that was last lecture I'm going
to review the results of it because what
I want to get to is how do you compute
the response by modal analysis the
response to a harmonic force but if you
for example if you get close to
resonance for a single degree of freedom
system what controls that height of that
peak
if you drive a single degree freedom
system at resonance what's the most
important parameter damping so we really
need to know damping and the way we get
damping is one of the ways is to measure
it so I want to measure the right
damping so that I can do what I'm trying
to get to is to do the forced vibration
problem but I need to get some estimates
of damping to do it now I said damping
can sometimes be a problem so I'm going
to show you my loaded to the stamp last
time but we didn't I wasn't able to kind
of really clearly go through it so I'm
going to make a damping model my damping
matrix for my system such that it is
proportional to the original mass and
stiffness matrices of the system so
alpha is just a parameter that I get to
choose beta is another one that I get to
choose and this is M and K the original
mass and stiffness matrices of this
problem or you know any n degree of
freedom problem we're doing these two
degree freedom examples because we get
there tractable on the board so if I
make my damping matrix look like that it
is guaranteed to work when I do u
transpose times that times u because we
know the mass and stiffness matrices
give me diagonals so I'm just
essentially doing it again so this is
guaranteed to give me a diagonal matrix
it's what I want yes yes these are the
original ones usually if I'm really
trying to write the mole
little ones all the drama with a
diagonal through them or something just
do so these are M and K just like up
here right there there right from the
original system they're the ones on the
top of this board there's the mass
matrix damping matrix stiffness matrix
for the original equations of motion so
I'm saying that my my unspecified
damping matrix which is written as c1 c2
there I'm going to represent it this way
so that you transpose C U which is the
calculation I need to be able to do what
that gives me is an alpha and here's my
modal mass diagonalize modal mass matrix
that results plus a beta at times to my
diagonalize stiffness matrices so
Christina these guys are the modal ones
after doing u transpose mu u transpose
ke ok so we have a two degree of freedom
system and when I do this calculation
I'll get modal mass M m1 m2 k1 k2 so
I'll get this the final diagonalized
stiffness matrix will end up looking
like some capital C 1 0 capital C 2 here
that's my diagonalized damping matrix
it'll come from these and I'll just
write them out so this C 1 will be an
alpha M 1 plus beta K 1 and C 2 the
alpha M 2 plus beta K 2 so I have two
free parameters with which I can fit I
can fit those parameters to give me the
damping that I want and I'm going to
measure the damping in the system and
then I'm going to find the two prime
does that make that work that's that's
why I'm going through this alright
run out of room
so Zeta one the damping ratio for mode
one normal V it's a single degree of
freedom system you say oh well that's
the damping constant over 2 Omega 1 M 1
that's how you that's how we define
damping ratio for a single degree
freedom system but we know what these
quantities are this then is an alpha M 1
over 2 Omega 1 M 1 plus a beta K 1 over
2 Omega 1 M 1 K 1 over m 1 Omega 1
squared right
so put a mega one squared up here cancel
with that these two gives you this gives
you alpha over 2 Omega 1 plus beta Omega
1 over 2 and I can do the same thing for
Zeta 2 be my C 2 over 2 Omega 2 m 2 and
that will give me an alpha over 2 Omega
2 plus beta Omega 2 over 2 so if I can
measure is a to a value for this damping
and a value for that damping I have
these are known then I have two
equations in two unknowns alpha and beta
just algebraic equations that I can
solve so now I need to conduct my
experiment
I have this system without external
excitations just the free vibration
system equations of typical equations of
motion like the first mode would look
like Q 1 M 1 Q 1 double dot plus C 1 Q 1
dot plus K 1 Q 1 equals 0 I'm looking
for solutions to that is a similar one
for the second mode and what I want to
do is excite one only one of these modes
at a time now you've seen this demo done
before but a certain combination of
deflections it will respond only in mode
1 and a different one will respond only
in mode 2 and it's guaranteed that if
you deflect a system in the shape of one
of its modes and let it go it will only
vibrate in that mode but let's prove to
ourselves if that actually is going to
work so
I'm going to let for example initial
conditions x10 x20 be in the shape of
mode 1
well mode 1 is 1 2 point 2 6 6 7 is the
mode shape of mode 1 alright I'm just
going to let that be that I'm going to
deflect it in the shape about 1 and then
we're going to let X 1 0 dot and X 2 0
dot those are 0 and I want to show I
want to I need to know well if I do that
what is what are the resulting initial
conditions in modal coordinates well we
know that Q 1 0 and Q 2 0 I can obtain
them by doing u inverse times this so
this will be u inverse and last time I'm
going to write this last time I made a
mistake
so u inverse I left out a 0 0.08 98.9
102 0.40 1/6 minus 0.40 1 6 so that's u
inverse and I'm going to multiply it by
1 of the mode shapes 1 & 2 point 2 6 6 7
so I'm saying that my initial conditions
are going to look exactly like 1 mode
shape to compute the equivalent modal
initial conditions I multiply the
generalizes for generalized equate the
coordinate initial conditions by u
inverse
here's u inverse
that and if I do that calculation I get
exactly one zero and if instead of the
first mode shape I put in the second
mode shape the 1 and minus 0.2 2 3 6 if
I did that I would get exactly 0 1 so I
just wanted to go through that just so
you'd see that if you the math bears it
out if you put in a deflection that's
exactly the shape of a mode then you
will get back an equivalent initial
condition in the modal coordinates for
only that mode and everything else will
be 0 so that's Q this is Q 1 0 is that
guy and this Q 2 0 in this case is 0
okay so now we're ready to do the
experiment so if I deflect it in the
shape of mode 1 back here and that would
be a good time to lower the lights a
little bit and unfortunately we have
that chalk white chalk in the background
to distract us but it's now deflected
only in the shape of mode 1 and now that
and it's going to behave like a single
degree freedom system right so how do
how would you estimate the do a quick
estimate of the damping of mode 1 I gave
you a little quick easy rule you could
use a few times back or was it
do the 50% thing she suggests now can
you be a little more specific pardon
yeah the how many what am I looking for
how many cycles it takes for the thing
to decay 50% so the reference line is
here I've deflected it that far and
it'll start vibrating and when the top
of this on a vibration gets to the
halfway point between here and the
reference references where it starts
that'll be my 50% so one two three or
got about four cycles when it only went
down halfway okay now one I did it in my
office the other day when I got two and
a half cycles so we're going to use two
and a half cycles because I ran the
numbers for that
it depends thing is very sensitive to if
it's inclined a little bit because that
changes the friction on the shaft so in
my office of that it was a lot more
damping so anyway pretend it's two and a
half okay now while we're at it let's do
the other let's do the other case so the
other case we want to deflect it in the
shape of mode two so I go down say a
unit amount it's now deflected downward
some amount and upwards such that the
ratio is in the mode shape of mode two
so every unit I went down I go up minus
twenty two percent of that so that's
what's been done here so when I release
this one now the reference line for the
second one is up here down to here so
when this upper one decays to a halfway
about here that'll be the number cycles
one two three four five six seven eight
ten anyway in my office I got about ten
okay we're going to use my numbers but
that one actually is clearly a lot less
damped right I think just went on and on
all right so in our experiment then so
we conducted our experiment
Zeta one is approximately equal to point
one one over the number of cycles to
decay fifty percent and when I did the
experiment in my office at was point one
one over two and a half so I mean it was
really decaying fast and so when you
only have two or three cycles yeah even
it helps to use even fractional cycles
and it's okay to use fractional cycles
this is just a nest against an estimate
that's going to give us a number theta
two is approximately point one one over
the number of cycles to decay fifty
percent and in this case that's going to
be ten and so that gives me zero point
zero one one or what's known as 1.1
percent damping okay and the other one
point one one over two-and-a-half gives
me zero point zero forty four or four
point four percent damping percent of
what and it remember what the percent
what's the what happens when you're at
one-half a damping ratio of 1.0 that's
critical damping that's a crossover
point if you have one or greater you get
no oscillation it just goes and stops
lesson one it will actually cross zero
and oscillate a little bit okay well so
now I have values for 0.0 44 and 0.01
one that I can plug in to these two
equations and I now have two equations
and two unknowns
in beta because I know Omega 1 and Omega
2 so solve for alpha and for alpha I'm
not going to do that on the board so
kind of a waste of good lecture time
10.7 T 1 and beta minus 0.03 3 so they
can be positive or negative to make
these work out but those are the two
values you need and that says that we're
going to model the damping matrix of the
system as 10 point 71 M plus minus zero
point O 3 3 K and we'll compute the
diagonalized damping matrix which is
comes from UT see you and did I write
that down
I didn't but I don't need it because I
know the damping that I'm after
Oh 44 and o11 because in order to
complete this problem if I wanted to go
to completion and have the transient
decay of the system I would have it in
for the each of the two prop two in the
two modal systems Q of T for the first
mode would be some e to the e to the
minus Zeta 1 Omega 1 T cosine Omega 1
whoops I need to get four left out my
q10 q10 cosine Omega 1 D times T that's
the initial most of the initial
displacement part plus q10 dot plus Zeta
Omega 1 Zeta 1 Omega 1 q10 all of that
over Omega 1 D all of this times sine
Omega 1 D times time so that's you know
this is just the response to initial
conditions for a single degree freedom
system and you'd have a similar one for
Q 2 of T except now all the ones would
be replaced by twos so you'd have an e
to the minus Zeta 2 Omega 2 T times and
those are your two that would that would
be in general the response to initial
conditions in modal terms and if you
want to get back to the final response
of in your generalized coordinates
and it's just summation I equals 1 to 2
in this case of you mode shape or mode 1
q1 plus mode Schaefer mode 2 q2 of T so
these two added together we give you
total response so that's the response
kind of a quick review of what we
learned before response to initial
conditions that now along the way we've
learned how to experimentally fix solve
fix the damping matrix so it'll work and
actually get us to give us exact the
accurate results if we want to do or
response to any initial conditions
problem but now we also have damping
ratios for the system and we can now go
on to do the force vibration problem the
force vibration problem will be pretty
easy at this point so that's that was a
quick review of response to initial
conditions bimodal analysis how to find
a damping matrix it works
we've also proven that if you deflect a
system in the shape of a mode it
responds only in that mode that's all
pretty use and that's generally true now
a vibration systems so we know like a
bang than this before we know these
things like to shake a little they're
flexible and this one has a mode shape
it's kind of a cantilever its first mode
it bends like that a little bit and this
thing has to Bend with it but if I were
able to just give this thing an initial
deflection just in the shape of that
mode and let it go it will vibrate in
just that mode and if I do it in some
other contorted way that it is that its
initial shape isn't just one mode let it
go it'll vibrate in a couple different
modes
of certain things or would they be the
center of masses of the spring yeah
there I thought a vibration course for
many many years and I scratched my head
long and hard to try to come up with an
example where you could do exactly what
you asked I know of one example that
works in general it the modal
coordinates are it's a coordinate
transformation into some system that
it's very hard to place yourself
physically so you can see what's going
on but it to answer your question I'll
show you one and still have enough time
to get through the other part imagine
this eraser it's a car car automobile
suspension system so here's a car sits
on Springs the tires and it's suspension
system got a center of mass they've here
somewhere and I'm only going to consider
vertical motion of this thing now you
can imagine that it could go up and down
but you can imagine can also pitch back
and forth right so I'm going to give two
generalized coordinates one is the
vertical deflection of its center of
mass and the other is the angular
rotation width of the center of mass
with respect to my initial horizontal
now so this you get equations of motion
to this one you'll get an MX double dot
kind of equation by summing the forces
on this and the F forces from the
springs and of course you'll have
dampers and those kind of things so
you'll have an one force equation by
summing the forces on it you'll have
another equation that summit torques and
it's a I theta double dot kind of
equation so you'll get it'll be a two
degree freedom system you get two
natural frequencies in two mode shapes
and the two natural frequencies look
proximate the two mode shapes look it
prepares the original undeflected system
one mode shape the system moves up and
rotates up has both positive rotation
and some positive deflection
and I need to draw this over here a
little further so here's the original
system it moves up in its mode shape
like that and when it goes down to its
max negative it's like that right so it
goes through a motion and if you think
about it if you extend these lines out
here you come to a point that this
intersects and so in fact in the first
mode of vibration of this thing if you
went and sat right here you would just
see this thing go through an angle and
that in fact is the modal coordinate for
mode 1 and the mode the second mode I've
kind of forgotten it it goes it has a
sign change and so when you're going
deflecting upwards it goes positive
flexion upwards it tips downwards and
when it goes the other way it goes like
that so the other mode so this one it
goes up and rotates up and the second
mode when it goes up it rotates down and
out here is the point at which you could
go sit there and you would just see this
thing rotate up rotate down if you went
and sat there so you're having to put
your move you move yourself to a place
where you can see with a single
coordinate with only the angle measured
about this point you can completely
describe that modal motion and with only
the angle measuring around this point
you can describe the modal motion but in
general you can't do it so if I'm out
here if I'm at my eyes at this point
I'll see the single like that okay that
help
those one of the hardest things for me
you know as a lecturer is since I really
like vibration and I've taught it for 35
years or so is to try to cram everything
I know about vibration into the one
third of this course so I obviously
don't do that so I'm trying to give you
my goal then becomes give you some basic
insight a vibration about vibration so
that when you do get out there in the
real world and you need to know
something you need to solve a vibration
problem you know the fundamentals and
you know where to go look it up and and
if you want to take another course or
something in vibration you can do that
all right now we've got to do in
relatively short order response of our
initial system over here to some
harmonic excitation and the one I've
chosen to do let's imagine that I just
if I'm just going to put a force a
harmonic force on this mass and I want
the steady state response and you can
imagine if I do it close to the natural
frequency of one of the modes you're
going to get a lot of that but if I do
it too close to the natural frequency of
the other mode
I'll get I can do it too so let's do the
steady-state harmonic excitation problem
so we're going to do this problem
f2 of T so my modal my generalized
forces are zero some magnitude F T e to
the I Omega T and the modal modal forces
are u transpose F and that would be the
calculation one and two point two six
six seven and one and minus point two
two three six my two mode shapes
transposed x 0 and F 2 so that says that
Q 1 is f 2 point 2 6 6 7 F 2 e to the I
Omega T Q 2 the modal force for mode 2
is this times that is minus 0.2 2 3 6 F
2 e to the I Omega T so I've put on just
a force on one mass but it gets
distributed in a way that it'll excite
both modes and it'll excite mode 1 in an
amount to point 2 times F 2 and it'll
excite mode 2 in an amount minus point 2
2
so mode 1 is going to get more
excitation in this particular case
because of the shape of the modes the
bigger the modal deflection is at the
point of application of the force the
more where that modes going to get
well now these give you just two
equations of motion M 1 Q 1 double dot
plus C 1 Q 1 dot K 1 Q 1 equals in the
case of mode 1 2 point 2 6 6 7 F 2 e to
the I Omega T and that's a single degree
freedom system excited by harmonic force
we've done we work that problem we know
what the answer looks like so for
example the magnitude of the response Q
1 is given by the magnitude of the force
Q 2 times the magnitude of a transfer
function which is the response Q 1 per
unit input force Q 1 evaluated at
whatever frequency I evaluated at so the
magnitude of the response magnitude of
the modal force times the transfer
function and this transfer function is
this is the exactly the same form as the
when we did just a single degree freedom
system as x over F it's what I called
the response x over input force F same
thing we're just now the response is Q
and input force is capital Q therefore
that looks like magnitude of Q and I
made a mistake here Q 1 magnitude of
force Q 1 which is this okay
times 1 over K 1 this should look
familiar
1 minus Omega squared over Omega 1
squared squared plus 2 Zeta 1 Omega over
Omega 1 quantity squared square root so
there's that transfer function
expression at resonance for example all
this goes to 0 Omega over Omega 1 goes
to 1 this whole denominator turns into 1
over 2 times the damping ratio for
example okay and Q 1 over K 1 is the
static deflection of the system under
the load under a static load of that
large so I'll do the problem if the
excitation frequency happens to be right
on the natural frequency for mode 1 and
I can evaluate this at 1 Omega over
Omega 1 is 1 and I've worked that out
that says that magnitude of Q 1 here to
point to 6 6 7 F 2 over K 1 times 1 over
2 Zeta 1 that's what all this condenses
to we know what K 1 is we know what Zeta
1 is F 2 is the thing we're specifying
and so Zeta 1 for example is what it was
point it was 4.04 4 so you plug in your
0.04 for here and this whole thing works
out to be should I write out write down
the numbers here to point to 6 6
7f2 over k1 is 109 84 and whoops not 109
that's K 2 1 1 3 point 71 times eleven
point three six which is 1 over 2 times
theta point out one over 0.08 8 is 11
point 36 this all the final analysis q1
is point two two seven f2 okay so it's
just a single degree freedom system
excited by harmonic force and you can
figure out how big its response is I
could do the same thing for mode two is
mode two resident resonant no
so this is instructive the magnitude of
the response of q2 is the magnitude of
the force times the magnitude of the hq2
per unit input - Q - Q looks like that
but this time this is - point two two
three six F - over 109 point 84 which is
K - and then all of the denominator
involving one - and this will now be
Omega over Omega 2 squared squared plus
2 Zeta 2 Omega over Omega 2 squared
square root or this number here is K -
the reason I'm going to this is this is
not where this one's not resonant and in
fact what's Omega ah well in fact what
is the X I I started this problem I said
let the excitation frequency be what
natural frequency mode 1 right so mega
in this case equals Omega 1 therefore
for this problem Omega over Omega 2 is
Omega 1 over Omega 2 and that's five
point six five something over 17 point
something it's about one third so we are
exciting the second mode at about one
third its natural frequency right and so
this is 1 minus a third quantity squared
and so forth and if I run the numbers I
just want to see what happens with the
numbers this turns out to be point 806
and this turns out to be with remember
this is 0.01 something here this number
turns out to be 5 times 10 to the minus
fifth it's a really small number and
this whole square root of this stuff
turns out to be 0.8 ninety-eight and an
end cue to works out the magnitude of q2
works out to be point zero zero to three
F - okay I kind of went I did this on
purpose if when you're at resonance
meaning the excitation frequency is
close to the natural frequency for any
linear vibration system then this term
is important and it'll be the most
important term in the denominator
because this term goes to zero it's the
only term in the denominator and it's
likely to be quite small that's what
gives you one over that a big response
but when you're not when this
denominator if you're not at resonance
this term almost always is negligible
and it's this term that governs it so
here you are 0.8 verses 10 to minus
fifth so away from resonance this term
is important and on resonance that one's
important and now how would you get back
to we've now got the two responses how
do we compute the total system response
how would you do it
the modal expansion theorem hmm yeah so
x equals you Q all right that's where we
started and q1 since this is a harmonic
excitation problem if the input had been
e to the I Omega T then the output is
some e to the I Omega t minus a phase
angle so this is going to look like some
q1 amplitude say cosine Omega 1 t minus
V 1 but at resonance we know the phase
angles PI over 2 and Q 2 of T it's going
to be the amplitude Q 2 times some
cosine Omega 1t because that's the
excitation frequency minus V 2 and
remember the each of these systems
these transfer functions H Q over Q for
whichever one it happens to be looks
like this different amounts of damping
give you different heights of the peak
at resonance and this is Omega over
Omega I so when you're at resonance
you're at one so what we've done is
we've have a two degree freedom system
we're exciting it at the natural
frequency of mode one so it means for
mode one we're right here let's say
that's where our damping is so that's
going to be our transfer function for
that mode but drawn on the same figure
where are we for mode two we're at Omega
1 over Omega 2 which is you know
somewhere in neighborhood of 0.3 so we
are in here so this is Omega over Omega
2 this is Omega over Omega 1 so down
here we're at about 0.3 here we're at
1.0 so at resonance for one of the modes
and we're here in what's called the
stiffness controlled region for the
other mode this mode mode 2 basically
acts like a spring okay the dynamic
amplification is about 1 it just gives
you the static response for mode 2 and
the resonant response for mode 1 so
I know what I was going to draw to
remind you this figure has a phase
diagram that goes with it in it for
lightly damped systems it goes from 0 to
PI and add resonance all of them cross
PI over 2 when it's a response to a
force simple force at resonance angle
phase angles PI over 2 so the response
lags the input by 90 degrees
when you're down here in this region the
response moves with the input their
phase angles basically zero and up in
here the phase angle is 180 degrees acts
like I'm driving a mass so our two
responses look like that and two back
get back into modal coordinates X 1 X 2
is going to look like u 1 Q 1 of T plus
u 2 Q 2 of T and the cute nd it's
harmonic steady state response you know
the amplitudes Q 1 and 2 2 we figured
them out one of them is 2 Q 1 turned out
to be point 2 2 7 F 2 and Q 2 is point 0
2 3 F 2
this one point cosine cosine so if we do
that if you put your excitation only on
here it's trying to tell you that mostly
you get mode one and not much mode two
but that's primarily cause because you
chose to put the excitation frequency at
where the natural frequency of mode one
right so your resident but what if I
could have so if I made my excitation
here same place but made the frequency
close to the natural frequency of mode
two which woke the two modes would have
dominated MOTU right okay so I've got
another little demo doing well
so we've talked out of necessity to do
it on the blackboard and in relatively
short time we've only talked about a two
degree of freedom to rigid body system
this is a continuous system it's a taut
string it's your violin string and I've
put some white label tags on it so you
can see it against black backgrounds
everything that we've learned about the
behavior of this two degree freedom
system will apply to a three or four or
five degree freedom system but actually
the basic lessons apply to continuous
systems - so the lesson we just learned
is if you excite a system this has many
natural frequencies in fact they if the
first ones at 1 Hertz which this is
about is maybe a little more than that
first mode is like that maybe 2 Hertz
the second mode is twice that third mode
three times that happens to be really
simple okay but if so if I put a force
the only force in this problem I'm going
to do the analogous problem here a
harmonic excitation I'm going to do it
in one little place right here and if I
drive this system at the natural
frequency of mode one what do you see
what mode is dominating response mode
one very very small responses of other
modes ok so now I get the system to stop
shaking if I Drive it at exactly the
same place at a different natural
frequency I see three half sine waves
there right so I was driving it at the
natural frequency of mode three and
there's no mode one no mode - okay now I
need a helper actually come hang on to
this for me
you got to keep the tension on it so now
I'm going to teach you a really
important lesson about systems exciting
systems the second mode I might have a
hard time driving in here let me see if
I can get the second mode going
their second mode has a node right here
the point right here of no motion right
if I sit here now I'm going to let the
system stop if I Drive this system at
the second mode natural frequency right
here what will happen pardon
maybe some only one by how much mode 2
will I get so another lesson here is
that if you drive continuous systems
have nodes points of manoa motion and
the second mode happens to have a node
right here this point doesn't move when
it's vibrating in the second mode and
the modal force looks something like the
generalized force times the mode shape U
transpose F that's how we got the you
have to multiply the generalized
external force times the mode shape to
get the modal force well here's my mo my
generalized force what's the amplitude
of the mode shape here 0 F times 0 is 0
I cannot there is just no way I can get
this thing to vibrate in the second mode
by driving it at a node and that's just
just just generally true you know take
it to the bank and remember that ok
thank you all right something else I
wanted to do ah I need you back
so when you give a system a deflection
and initial deflection because we want
when we got one to get initial
conditions we said that the equivalent
modal initial conditions were u inverse
times the U inverse times the initial
conditions and generalized coordinates
right so for a continuous system this
thing has mode shapes that look like
sine n PI x over L those are the mode
shapes and I probably take this thing I
grabbed it about in the middle where of
that node was and given an initial
deflection the shape of that initial
deflection is kind of a triangle right
you've all had Fourier series could you
this is a triangular shape could you
express this shape as a Fourier sine
series sure and it just happens that
sine waves of the mode shapes so you
would be coming up them the Fourier
coefficients are the modal amplitudes of
in initial conditions and so whatever
the Fourier coefficients for this are
are the modal amplitudes for each of the
modes so which mode do you think is gone
which Fourier sine component is going to
be largest in this one mode one by the
way all even-numbered modes will be zero
because they're asymmetric this is a
symmetrically shaped pulse all the modal
initial conditions for two four six
eight ten are zero you will get for e a
nonzero Fourier coefficients for one
three five seven the biggest one is mode
one so what do you expect to see if I
let go of this vibration primarily at
right and a little bit of some others
now let's say they all had about the
same damping let's say they all had 5%
10% damping oqv all had 1% damping that
means they go through about 10 cycles to
decay to half way right so if they all
have the same damping even if there are
several other modes present which ones
are going to last longer in time mode
one because it takes just longer in time
to get to ten cycles the other modes get
there quicker and so this have you ever
whacked if you take a guitar string and
plunk it or a violin or piano you'll
hear the basic tone and what makes it
sound nice you have those nice overtones
but if you listen carefully the
overtones die out usually and you're
left with the fundamental at the end you
smack a piano key hard you'll get you'll
get an interesting sound at the
beginning and then it'll mellow out on
your head just a pure tone at the end
and that's because the data of the
higher frequencies damp out quicker
because they get in more cycles per unit
time okay that's the other kind of quick
lesson I want I have one thing I want to
explain to you which will help
maybe a little conceptual understanding
about this came up in a homework
discussion and that is just a note about
stiffness matrices
is a really fast easy way to assemble
stiffness matrices so here's a three
mass system and a spring spring spring
and I'm going to put a spring here and
one here
k1 k2 k3 k4 k5 and k-6
and I want to get my stiffness matrix
stiffness matrix this is a three degree
freedom system it'll be a three by three
and it'll have elements up here which
I'll call K 1 1 K 1 2 K 1 3 K 2 1 K 2 3
ok 3 1 K 2 2 and so forth ok so what's
the meaning of K I J so KX o K 1 1 is 1
J is 1 and the interpret if you can
understand the interpretation of what a
stiffness matrix is it'll help you make
it much easier for you to find them so K
IJ is the force required at I
due to a unit deflection at J due to
sounds kind of like caused a causal
thing I don't quite mean that but so
let's think about this what's K 1 1 so k
1 1 is the force required at 1 per unit
deflection at 1 so if I take this system
and I make it move over one unit and the
other this is now X 1 here by the way X
1 X 2 X 3 so X 2 and X 3 are 0 I do this
one at a time I move this over 1 unit
how much force does it take to make that
happen the real system you're grabbing
it you're pulling it over 1 unit you're
making some Springs move how much force
does it take to move that one one unit
holding these still well you're going to
one force on a spring is KX if X is 1
the force required to stretch this
spring is k1 times 1 right the force
required to push on that spring is K 5
times 5 k2 times K 5 times 1 K 2 times 1
the first the k1 one this first element
is the sum of all of the stiffness
Springs connected to it K 1 plus K 2
plus K 5 so how about k12 k12 is the is
the force required at one actually let
me do K 2 1 make a little more sense is
the force required at 2 because I've
moved number move the system one unit at
1 that's what the problem that's this
thing I've done I've move this one unit
in order to keep this one for moving do
I have to apply force to it
how big k2 or minus k2 this thing is
pushing going over one unit it
compresses that spring it's pushing on
this thing I see it cannot move what do
I have to do push you back - k2 and you
can go through and then how about number
three what's the force required at at
three because I've moved the one at one
by one unit move this over
are there any Springs connected to mass
three that are affected by that motion
k5 and it pushes on it through that
spring so I have to resist by so k3 1
equals minus k5 and you can then so now
then you go on to if you want to get the
next ones okay you go to the next system
this is now can't move this can move and
let this be unit deflection so unit
deflection at to add up the springs k2
plus k3 plus k-6 and that's all there is
okay to to k2 plus k3 plus k-6 and then
you go through all the ones that it
affects and you'll get minus this and
that so that's the meaning that's the
each of the elements of that stiffness
matrix have that meaning to it and to
give this closure we have any we have
equation of motion but we can know the
stiffness matrices also applies to the
statics problem so you have M X double
dot plus CX dot plus KX equals F what if
I only want to do a statics problem I'm
going to put a static force on here and
I want to know the deflections or I'm
going to cause deflections and I want to
know what force it takes to do it
well the static problem is you let this
be 0 this be 0 and it says K x equals F
so in this three degree of freedom
system what forces are required to cause
the deflection zero zero one I want to
deflect it one unit on the third mass
only what forces do I apply to the
system to make it happen well you just
multiply it out this is F 1 F 2 F 3 so
it'll only be this one this times this
this and this the only ones that matter
are these three here and this will end
up being K 3 1 times 1 this would be K
ok so I got it around 1 3 and we get 2 1
2 2 2 3 K 3 3 those are the three forces
required you put on the force those
forces force is equal to these amounts
you will get that deflection so that's
just a little hope that gives you a
little insight as to what stiffness
matrices mean
okay so there's you can do them by
inspection once you understand that you
can actually just fill them in by
inspection just by doing unit
displacements at each place and add
enough to forces okay see you on
Thursday